remember when Donald Trump told Hillary
Clinton that if he was in charge she
would be in jail let's play that video
just to jog your memory about this you
know it is it's just awfully good that
someone with the temperament of Donald
Trump is not in charge of the law in our
country because you'd be in jail
Secretary Clinton since the election
Donald Trump has said that actually
investigating or jailing Hillary Clinton
just isn't a priority but now Donald
Trump has actually made it clear it was
all a ruse from the beginning to
bamboozle in for low information voters
from the get-go Trump has been doing
this hilarious thank-you tour 2016 and
he stopped in Grand Rapids Michigan a
few days ago and at some point when
Trump was talking about who knows what
the crowd started chanting locker up and
Trump had a surprisingly honest response
here is a tweet from NBC News's
Alexandra Jaffe who said whoa chant of
lock her up from the crowd
Trump replies that plays great before
the election now we don't care and we
have video of Donald Trump admitting it
was just a way to bamboozle people into
voting for him here's the video right
because I heard my opponent had
scheduled Michigan unexpectedly it was
like all of a sudden with President
Obama and Michelle and Bill and Hillary
and they were going to Michigan now
Tucker now forget it
that plays great before the election now
we don't care right the rare honest
reaction from Donald Trump I marked it
on my calendar when I saw this pad is
the day where Trump Trump said something
honest Trump made headlines during his
campaign when he said I'm gonna assign a
special prosecutor to investigate
Hillary Clinton's FBI email situation
I'm gonna put her in jail for how she
handled those classified emails lock her
up was a key slogan on the on the
campaign trail Trump played these morons
for fools he was never
prosecutor Hillary Clinton from the day
he said it it was clear it was never
happening yeah and I mentioned this
earlier in the program but I mean
locking up your political opponents
that's something reminiscent of
authoritarian regimes in developing
countries yeah it just makes you wonder
which of his campaign promises are up
for negotiation now yeah I guess
whichever one someone mentions to him in
the five minutes before he has to make a
decision on it cuz that's all he seems
to be able to remember this is the mo of
a huckster you say that before it
doesn't matter now and obviously a lot
of politicians do this but you're not
supposed to admit that it was just
something you said for votes and never
intended to do now this this is this is
just gonna make you your head explode if
you're any in any way connected to the
real world
how are the trumpets defending what
Donald Trump said well some are actually
angry and tweeting about it but there
are some trumpets that are defending
what Trump said by saying hey guys it's
not Trump's role Trump can't investigate
Hillary Clinton and lock her up it's up
to Jeff Sessions the incoming Attorney
General that is certainly one way to
make excuses for the blatant lies of the
campaign trail it's almost like the
Trump supporters didn't understand the
intricacies of what the president can
and cannot do no no doubt about it and
when it comes to trade wars with China
when it comes to the wall with Mexico
all great ideas that people want and
then they have no understanding of if
and how those things would actually be
carried out in the real world Gamefly is
sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s